[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right this is a segment if you're
unfamiliar this is a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
and they do it because we dare them to
we dare our viewers try and find a
single small small flaw in our show that
was right that one right there shut up
right there but seriously we dare them
to try and find something so far
hundreds of challengers not one winner
they think they find a flaw and then
turns out we're right well tonight a fan
named Carson Seaver says he thinks he
caught a mistake he says it happened
during a recent interview with Christina
Applegate the first ride we put her on
was Peter Pan and all of a sudden you
just heard blood-curdling streaming from
my childhood people have come here since
like 1950 something you know yeah that's
cons a two-year-old down people but
coming here since Truman was president
but you were wrong Truman was president
1945 to 1953 almost two years later
Disneyland open not only is this an
insult to the integrity of your show
this is an insult to the wipe D
Eisenhower who is from my home state
Kansas Yahoo Conan
[Applause]
I think it's clear Carson just went to
the chessboard because he ran out of
animals do his parents know he's
operating a small farm sort of petting
zoo I want to make this clear all right
Carson he seems like a very funny kid
very creative I thought you did a
terrific job brother see I'm lucky to
have such smart creative fans but I'm
sorry to tell you a Carson you're dead
wrong you just are wrong
you see the Peter Pan ride was opened
during the Truman administration if you
don't believe me it's time for a little
history lesson watch this authentic
newsreel footage
from 1955 to Disneyland for a chance to
ride the brand-new Peter Pan ride
thrills and excitement for all and on
this very same day Harry Truman was
sworn in as president there is Biggs
wanted by McGee and attendants are
Donald Minnie and there's goofy that
makes Truman the first president under
whom people could use the Peter Pan ride
they said information is abuse in the
future good day
[Applause]
anyway that challenge still stands if
you think you've spotted an error on our
show reported at team koco.com slash ha
ha I found that ever we will sort it out
right here on the air let's see if
you've got what it takes to make junk
meat out of the maestro wasn't that a
great clip subscribe to my youtube
channel for an endless supply of me
[Laughter]